おはようバーン
t
ようやく見つけましたあの僕かなーり昔に目がゴキブリっていうめちゃくちゃデッキ
れいこギブリでドッキリしたことなんですけども
ああああっ
どうぞ
スケブは大金
トカゲ改定なぁと思いましてやっぱ責任もって買うことが僕多分できないと思ったんで
一環にリアルで巨大なトカゲが売ってねーかと思って調べたところをようやくネットで
見つけましたこちら
モザイク解除
いやーやばいな俺にグンナー好きなんですけど高木頑張れ得意じゃないんですよね
じゃあなんで買うんやって話よ
なんでどうやったこれ作った梅原か
俺さー
はジェルいいんだけどねシッポが苦手なんですよねだっても私1本でゆるすぎこれ上
はまってなければバウンドパン買ってこいてやる
うわぁ
re
ええええええ
俺あぁんって呼的にははてこんな金具に無理感とか媚薬だったらすごいやだな
うわぁ
怖い
いい
山なれるし金も触ってくれるしかねやってんけども誰しかないで俺が誰ですかね俺は
80ミリのなり方オレは二つで失点でもうね
触って慣れるしかないんだよもうねほらねぇっちゃリアルなんですよ顔まねそんな
ちょっとままちょっと作ったがあるんですけど変わらないのって言ってるがもう本人な
んですよ足とか病ジャーってもマジでね
ほっこいいんですよ体の柔らかさとか本物だよ俺これ触ったことだけどわかるんですよ
ね
うーん
バウンドかなんだろうすごい本人幸あればパッと言ったらまつげなくホームのぞみまず
良いでしょう動画税制見た時の巨大トカゲもこれくらいのサイズ感だったんでもう大
キター
dd る感覚にはなかったつべにおいてかなり本物に近いと思います僕方もなさ私見
たらね僕の記憶が正しければまずです
スゴイねこれというわけで今日は空沿いと影を使って特急していこうと思いますもう
慣れたもう慣れた俺は慣れだよいやほんとは買いたいんではこういう小型望むところで
あるいったらすごいかわいいじゃん
何だろう no というわけで今朝と父15分
謎足がこんな時間まで徹夜で起きていたかと言いますとターゲットが出るのを待ってい
ました
いうわけでの上にターゲットはグッズでているので撮っおっきて隣にとカビがいたら
どんな毛幸せなのかと幸せかもちょっと見ていこうと思います
では行こうよ
うん
[音楽]
あ
ani came
[音楽]
白のに
ねぇ尻尾を受けて置いておきます
4日
バッハ
おっ
びっくりし等
おおぉおおぉ珍しいな
きっ
ですねおっちゃんですねこれ例のアレにビックリしましそう
[音楽]
パッ
やっぱり
wh
大変
[音楽]
ねえ絶対避けたい日本の絶景を訪れた言えない手を焼いてんだよ
なにこの猿回ってない次ものテレビ共助と言うんですよね
だからっ
nan ん
ええええええ
me
car
バッハ